chào các bạn video này à sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn cách sử dụng bước nhảy tá để
soạn thảo một văn bản dạng biểu mẫu hay
còn gọi là dạng form dạng biểu mẫu đó
như bên trái màn hình đây ha thì trong
cái bài này thì chúng ta sẽ sử dụng bước
nhảy Tab và có cái điểm khác biệt là khi
chúng ta nhấn phím Tab thì nó có tạo ra
cái dấu chấm như thế này cái dấu chấm
này gọi là dấu D
và dấu dẫn này được tạo ra khi chúng ta
nhấn Tab chứ không phải là chúng ta gọi
dấu chấm trực tiếp trên bàn phím nha À
đó là điểm khác biệt của cái bài tạo
form này Và bây giờ chúng ta bắt đầu
thao tác chúng ta gõ tiêu đề trước hó
đơn cước vẫn chuyển à chúng ta lưu ý
là phần tiêu đề chúng ta cứ gõ bình
thường cho chúng ta đừng có bật CP Block
lên gõ Lát nữa chúng ta đổi sang chữ hoa
nha cứ gõ bình thường vậy
à giữa chữ ngày và chữ tháng á là chúng
ta sẽ gọi dầu chấm nha Chúng ta không
dùng táp vì cái này chúng ta không cần
thiết phải dùng Tab nó không Căn theo
đối tượng nào hết rồi và bây giờ chúng
ta bắt đầu gọ cái dòng đầu tiên là dòng
n này đây thì cái dòng này là nó có bước
nhảy táp các bạn đây thì lúc đầu con trọ
nằm bên trái này chúng ta nhấn táp nó
nhảy qua chữ N này và gọi chữ N xong
nhấn táp nó nhảy về C cuối bă bản này và
hai bước táp này nó khác nhau ở chỗ là
cái bước táp thứ hai là Khi Chúng Ta
nhấn á thì nó có dấu chấm nha Và bây giờ
chúng ta xem cái mẫu này chúng ta sẽ
định nghĩa bước táp tại vị trí 11 và
15,5 đặt rõ vào dòng sẽ gõi chữ N đây là
bước táp cân
trái và chúng ta đặt vào vị trí số 11
nhấp và 15,5
nhấp chúng ta có được hai bước Táp và
chúng ta nhấn phím Tab chúng ta gõ vào n
ha ch
T thì khi chúng ta nhấn phím t để chúng
ta gọi chữ N ấy
đây và sau đó Nhấn phím táp Á tiếp á thì
C trọ Nó nhảy về cuối nhưng mà cái táp
Thứ hai này này này táp này này là phải
có dấu chấm thì chúng ta định nghĩa dấ
chấm bằng cách nhập đôi chuột vào biểu
tượng Tab trên thước Khi nào chúng ta
trỏ chuột vào cái thước khi nào con trỏ
chuột nó xuất hiện chữ left T thì chúng
ta nhấp
đôi và chúng ta chọn cái Tab thứ hai là
15.5 này N và Tab này sẽ có dấu dẫn là
dấu chấm thì chúng ta chọn tá này chọn
số 2 số 2 là một dạng dấu dẫn chấm liên
tục này và chọn set Ok chúng ta có được
dều dẫn và tương tự chúng ta nhấn enter
nhấn Tab g bõ vào chữ có hai chấm Nhấn
TP đấy thì cái bước nhảy táp chúng ta đã
định nghĩa ở dòng n rồi và cho nên dòng
có nó tự động nó mang xuống chúng ta
không cần phải định nghĩa nữa nha rồi
nhấn enter gõ tiếp họ tên khách
hàng và hai chấm chúng ta nhấn Tab này
Tab đầu tiên là nó dừng ở vị trí 11 Tab
này không có dấu dẫn kệ nó chúng ta nhấn
Tab tiếp đây và bây giờ này với dòng họ
tên khách hàng này chúng ta không cần
phải dùng táp tại vị trí số 11 này thì
chúng ta sẽ xóa nó bằng cách trỏ chuột
vào biểu tượng Táp Và kéo xuống màn hình
Xóa đi
đây và nó tạo ra một cái dòng thứ hai
chúng ta có thể để vậy cũng được chúng
ta xóa đi được chúng ta gõ nhấn enter
chúng ta gõ địa
chỉ hai ch F
enter phương tiện vận
chuyển
À ha ch
f rồi bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nhấn enter để
tiếp tục dòng là đi từ và đến và dòng đi
từ và đến này á thì nó khác với dòng
phương tiện vận chuyển là nó sẽ có hai
BC táp bậc táp thì thứ nhất tại vị trí
chữ d màu đỏ này nè và bước táp này cũng
tạo dấu dẫn bước táp thứ hai là ở cuối
dòng cũng tạo dấ dẫn à chúng ta sẽ tạo
bước táp tại vị trí chữ d này còn bước
táp ở vị trí cuối cùng nó có rồi Các bạn
nhìn trên thướng này đây trên thướng đây
này À nó có rồi cho nên chúng ta sẽ tạo
bước tạp tại vị trí chữ D thôi và chúng
ta đặt con trọ tại vị trí Ví dụ như số 8
chúng ta tạo một BC TP trái và chúng ta
gõ đi từ 2i chấm t đến 2i chấm t mà
chúng ta quan sát là có sự khác biệt là
TP Thứ hai này có dấu dẫn mà táp đầu là
chưa có vì chúng ta chưa định nghĩa thì
bây giờ chúng ta định nghĩa này chúng ta
nhập đôi chuột vào biểu tượng táp tại vị
trí số 8 này nhập đôi vào nha đó chúng
ta chọn TP là số 8 chọn 2 chọn s và ok
là chúng ta tạo được là cái dấu chấm đấy
Hay là còn gọi là định dàng dấu dẫn nhấp
đây và chúng ta quan sát ví dụ chúng ta
thấy rằng là chữ đến nó lịch phải quá
Chúng ta muốn dịch qua trái một chút thì
chúng ta đặt con trỏ vào dần đó chúng ta
trỏ vào bước táp thứ nhất là tại vị trí
C số 8 này chúng ta kéo lịch qua này nhớ
là kéo lịch qua mà nhả chuột trên thước
là di chuyển nha Chứ còn nếu chúng ta
nhả chuột ở dưới văn bản như thế này này
là xóa bây giờ chúng ta sẽ di chuyển tại
vị trí số 7 r 7.5 đây rồi nhấn enter
gõ ngày
đi 2 chm T ngày
đến hai dòng này nó có cái táp giống
nhau cho nên chúng ta không cần định
nghĩa nữa nhấn enter tiếp tục hình thức
thanh toán
hai chấm Nhấn táp Thứ nhất Nó nhảy đến
vị trí số 7.5 nhấn táp thứ hai nó nhảy
đến là 15.5 thì cái TP tại vị trí 7.5
này này chúng ta không cần phải sử dụng
nó chúng ta nhập vào 7.5 đây t này kéo
xuống màn hình để xóa nó đi đây và dòng
này có thể chúng ta để được mà không để
được chúng ta xóa đi cho dễ thao tác và
nhấn enter tiếp tục dọng tên sản phẩm Mã
số đơn vị tính thì tại một vị trí màu đỏ
trên cái dòng đó chúng ta phải đặt một
bước táp Tại vì đây từ tên sản phẩm nhấn
táp nó nhảy qua mã số từ mã số Nhấn táp
nó nhảy qua đơn vị tính từ đơn vị tính
nhấn táp nó nhảy vào cuối dòng thì vị
trí cuối dòng bao giờ nó cũng có sẵn rồi
vì chúng ta lúc nãy giờ chúng ta dùng
cho chúng ta không xóa nó do vậy chúng
ta sẽ tạo hai cái táp tại vị trí chữ m
này và chữ d này nha thì chữ m ước chừng
vị trí số số 5 chữ d ước chừng ở vị trí
số
10 và chúng ta gõ tên sản
phẩm nhânn tá mã
số 2i chm nhận tá tên vị
tính nhận
táp rồi và chúng ta quan sát là hai cái
bước táp đầu chưa có có Diệu dẫn thì
chúng ta định nghĩa chúng ta đặt trỏ vào
dòng tên sản phẩm trỏ chuột vào biểu
tượng táp bất kỳ trên thước khi nó xuất
hiện laptop thì nhấp đôi
chuột và chọn TP 5 cm chọn 2 chọn set
táp 10 cm chọn 2 chọn set vì chúng ta
thiết lập cái dấu dẫn cho hai táp đầu
tiên cho nên lần lượt chúng ta nhấp vào
5 chọn hai chọn set và 10 chọn hai chọn
set rồi ok nha đây chúng ta có dữ dẫn và
tiếp tục chúng ta nhấn enter xuống dòng
chúng ta gõ số
lượng
đây nhưng mà cái dòng số lượng này này
và cái dòng mã tên sản phẩm nó Tab nó
khác nhau Phả nhưng mà chúng ta quan sát
này cái dòng số lượng này nè t nó giống
với cái dòng ngày đi ngày đến cho nên
chúng ta sẽ copy cái Tab của dòng ngày
đi ngày đến xuống cho dòng số lượng và
cách thao tác nà chúng ta chọn dòng ngày
đi ngày đến nhấp vào
cái cái chối gọi là format painter gọi
là định dạng theo đối tượng nhấp vào Sau
đó chúng ta quét vào dòng số lượng này
nhấp này đây và lúc này cái dòng số
lượng sẽ được định dạng như cái dòng
ngày đi ngày đến và chúng ta chỉ việc
nhận t gõ vào đơn giá chúng ta không cần
định nghĩa T nữa vì chúng ta đã copy
dòng trên xuống rồi
đây và cuối cùng chúng ta sẽ làm tương
tự là thành
tiền rồi hai chấm tab tab chúng ta xóa
Tab ở giữa đi à Xin lỗi là xóa Tab ở đầu
tiên đi ở tiếp tục nha Bây giờ chúng ta
sẽ gõ tiếp cái dòng là viết bằng
chữ dòng này thì chúng ta khỏi phải à
định dạng gì cả vì nó copy cái dòng
thành tiền
Nà Rồi à tiếp tục nhấn enter và nhấn Tab
lần nữa để tạo ra dòng Trống Và bây giờ
này chúng ta sẽ tạo hai
cái cái tiêu đề ở phía dưới là người lập
phiếu và kế toán chúng ta nhận enter khi
chúng ta nhận enter ấy thì cái dòng mới
tậ tạo ra này này nó cũng mang Tab của
dòng trên nhưng mà cái dòng là người lập
phiếu và kế toán á là không dùng cái TP
đó nữa cho nên chúng ta xóa đi thì cách
xóa là chúng ta sẽ nhắp chuột vào biểu
tượng táp chúng ta kéo xuống màn hình
cách thứ hai là chúng ta Xóa hết được
Tab thì chúng ta nhấn Ctrl Q nha Ctrl q
các bạn nha đó Xóa hết thì như vậy chúng
ta quan sát trên thước là nó không còn
cái biểu tượng táp nữa Và bây giờ chúng
ta sẽ gõ dòng là người lập phiếu và kết
toán thì thì để gõ cái người lập phiếu
kế toán này chúng ta sẽ tạo hai cái bước
táp cân giữa tại hai vị trí đó và chúng
ta đặt trỏ tại dòng sẽ gõ vào người lập
phiếu kế toán chúng ta nhập chuột vào
biểu tượng táp và chuyển qua táp cân
giữa và chúng ta ước chừng là ở vị trí
số 4 và vị trí số
à và chúng ta gọ nhấn Tab chúng ta gọ
người lập phiếu
nhấn Tab gõ vào là kế
toán và nhấn enter xuống dòng nhấn Tab
tiếp mở ngoặc ghi rõ họ
tên và lại tiếp tục nhấn
t ghi nội dung tương
tự và giải thích n Tại sao ở đây chúng
ta sẽ dùng bước nhả tá là kênh giữa mà
không dùng kênh trái chúng ta quan sát
là người lập phiếu và ghi rõ họ tên này
nó CN giữa tại một điểm và kế toán và
ghi rõ họ tên cũng vậy
và chúng ta dùng tác trong trường hợp
này này và chúng ta thấy là chúng ta rất
dễ dàng để di chuyển nó các bạn quan sát
nha thì chúng ta chọn hai dòng đây chọn
hai dòng này chúng ta muốn dịch chuyển
cái phần là kế toán qua bên phải thì
chúng ta chỉ việc trọ và biểu tượng Tab
ở vị trí số 11 này chúng ta kéo qua phải
à Các bạn thấy nó dịch chuyển qua nha
tương tự như vậy người lập phiếu chúng
ta muốn dịch sang trái thì chúng ta chỉ
việc là trỏ vào biểu tượng áp trên con
số 4 á kéo qua trái nà đây Vậy thôi là
xong và chúng ta thực hiện một vài các
thao tác cuối cùng như là chúng ta định
dạng ví dụ hó đơn cước vận chuyển chúng
ta chuyển sang chữ hoa à in đậm canh
giữa tăng saz
lên đây ngày tháng 5 này chúng ta lại C
giữa và chúng ta chuyển sang cách Việ
thông thường là sentenc ke đấy và chúng
ta kết thúc cái bài
này xin chào các bạn